you've been married for 29 years is that
correct a long time okay what's a good
way to have longevity in a relationship
find someone
fantastic I found my well I was I was
lucky I met Sarah Jane in the schouest
way playing Romeo and
Julia when we were very young she came
into the readr and she was wearing
glasses and had a pile of books she'
been sort of buying secondhand books
from loads of bookstores she's little
late she was dropping the books and her
glasses and I I fell for it right
now playing Romeo and Juliet do you see
this is like we all have these romantic
fantasies and yours is
real
okay forgive me luckily your show uh is
patient with those who don't speak
French perfect perfectly um Monsur spade
a dashel Hammond novel Scott Frank
another incredible filmmaker hot off the
Queen's Gambit um I've been watching the
show it's remarkable the first episode
ends with an amazing Cliffhanger and
like you really know like what you're in
for at that moment did I just tell you
everything that you were going to say
about the show no I I can say other
things please
do no it's um well it's take you know
Scott who I'm and have been a fan of for
so many years he so he calls me up and
he pitches me the idea of doing Sam
Spade 20 years later living in the south
of France but it also still gave me the
opportunity to go back and drown in
Bogart look at those movies feel like
cuz I you know I go well that's where he
comes from though even though we're here
he has to feel like we know that that's
the guy the private detective from that
era who's now getting older and trying
to sort of live a quieter life